[Music]
no matter what our dog does we will
always call him a good boy
and cats birds and goats are not better
when we ask them to follow the rules
that's why all these funny animals ended
up on the naughty list just wait until
you see a bird who decided that no one
could tell it where to go if you love
animals as much as we do
don't forget to subscribe and please
give this video a big thumbs up today
we're showing you ten naughty animals
who don't care about the rules no dogs
allowed dogs are the most beautiful
thing this world ever gave us and if
there is one thing better than a puppy
it's two puppies this is why we're
disappointed when we see a sign reading
that dogs are not allowed why can't we
take the love of our lives
everywhere we go dogs are irresistible
and we think that everyone will agree
with us as soon as they see their
beautiful faces unfortunately some
people have a heart of stone and won't
let us bring our dogs to the beach this
is why these funny creatures decided to
take the matter into their own hands or
in their own mouth and show them that
the rules are meant to be broken they
just took the sign and decided to play
with it after all it is made with a
beautiful stick no dog can resist the
temptation and those who made the rule
should have known about that and we
think that we should listen to these
beautiful dogs if dogs aren't allowed on
the beach humans shouldn't go there
either after all they are the ones who
keep throwing trash everywhere who don't
mind breaking things and who scream like
nobody's around this is why we think
that we should make a beach just for
dogs and their well-behaved owners and
it would be the most perfect place in
the world dogs only ok maybe creating a
beach only for dogs and their
well-behaved owners is not the best idea
this is why we should create a place
where all the animals could live in
peace and have fun together
the only rule would be that they need to
be extremely cute and nice to everyone
that's an easy thing to do for perfect
creatures like that unfortunately you're
either a cat or a dog person and some
people clearly prefer puppies they
decided that only dogs were allowed on
the equipment this is why this naughty
cat decided to fight against
discrimination it thinks that every
animal should have the same rights
so if dogs can do it cats can do it
better and it won't take time before
this big kitten shows off his skill to
prove that he deserves a place in this
dog park and don't worry kitty we think
that you will win this fight by writing
dogs only they probably meant the
humans are not allowed on the equipment
they just didn't think that someone
walked their cat on a leash to bring it
to the dog park and play but there has
to be a first to everything and this cat
is here to change the world in his own
way
that's the right way to do it kitty
upside down one of the first things that
you want to teach a puppy is that they
need to go to the bathroom outside or at
least use the pee pee pad in the house
it's hard to clean up everything during
the first month but once they learn how
it works we can't help but love
everything about them you might think
that puppies know how to pee since the
day they are born but we think that we
found an exception to this rule this dog
doesn't only lift one paw he lists both
that's how he pees upside down and the
weirdest thing is that he can even walk
while peeing there is pee everywhere
because of this but we don't mind
because this is too funny it's already
really difficult for dogs to walk like
humans so imagine what it's like for him
to walk on his two front paws we haven't
seen any other dog doing anything like
this this pug is a true circus artist
however we're happy that no human ever
tried to do anything like this yes it
might be impressive to see people
walking on their hands but we want to
make sure that they keep their pants on
when they do that
peeing upside down is something that we
can forgive only when you're a cute
little dog there is no way a human is
going to get away with that do not look
if you come back home and see that your
dog destroyed everything in the house it
is your problem how dare you leave this
poor creature alone all day they thought
that you were never coming back and this
is why they decided to use anything they
could defined as a distraction and this
big puppy is probably one of the
naughtiest ones no matter if he's inside
or outside he finds something to destroy
and the funniest thing is that he
doesn't want to admit it when his owner
finds him he just looks away like he
doesn't know what happened and simply
for being incredibly cute we can forgive
anything this dog is doing but did you
know that dogs actually never feel any
guilt this is a too complicated feeling
for most animals so they just don't
really mind when they break something
they simply learned that when they do
something bad you scold them and this is
what they want to avoid
so these puppy dog eyes are there only
to manipulate you and make sure that you
will still love them we totally
understand why our best friends are
doing that because it totally works and
if we had a dog who acted like this
puppy looking away we would almost ask
it to destroy everything in our home
they look too cute when they pretend to
feel guilty stay in the cage we would
like our dogs to have the right to play
around the house
much as they want to but unfortunately
some of them destroy everything and this
is why we have to force them to stay in
the cage all day it becomes their little
home where they can feel safe and
comfortable but not all dogs like to
stay in this place
when you ask this husky to go in his
cage he pretends that he misunderstood
one word and goes on his cage instead he
would probably say that this is because
the world looks more beautiful up there
no one wants to spend the day stuck in a
tiny cage mostly when you're a big dog
full of energy and there is no way this
big puppy is going to listen even if you
put some very comfortable blankets in
his cage we have to admit that we
totally understand him as humans we
wouldn't like our room to be as big as
our bed and this big puppy deserves
better however he will have to prove
that he can be a good boy before he gets
the right to run around the house all
day but with this beautiful look it
probably won't take too much time before
his owner gives him the chance to do
whatever he wants no one can resist the
power of the puppy-dog eyes do not climb
on rocks you might think that dogs and
cats are the funniest pets you could
ever have but they have some competition
that's because goats are some of the
weirdest animals we ever saw they're
just always playing and climbing on
stuff and have you ever seen them when
they fall they are hilarious
we don't know about you but we think
that goats are the new pets that
everyone should adopt if they want a
smile every day and if you don't think
that this is a good idea this naughty
boy will change your mind the sign reads
please do not climb on rocks but this
funny creature couldn't care less he
even took the time to pose for a picture
just to prove that no one could keep him
from climbing on whatever he wants
after all goats can't read so he is not
responsible if he doesn't understand but
how do goats get their incredible
climbing skills that's because they use
height for protection from predators
kids can start climbing with their
parents when they're just days old now
we understand why these little creatures
are so good when they grow up and even
though they have nothing to be afraid of
when they live with us we think that it
is really fun to see that they kept this
weird habit don't forget to chew for a
Pug eating is the most important part of
the day they sleep all the time because
they can't wait for the next time they
will have the chance to eat and cuddles
are always here to comfort them when
they are sad because there is no food
and don't ever let it dinner be one
minute late because the owner will
quickly know about it when the Pug will
start barking every meal is the most
important meal of the day
and we should not forget it
unfortunately eating is more difficult
than it should be for some pugs to eat
but this funny dog is an exception
he doesn't chew his food he inhales it
and then he chokes he pukes and eats it
we don't know how evolution managed to
create one ridiculous creature like that
but we think that it must be hilarious
and we all laugh when we see how an
owner decided to shame his poor little
dog this big puppy doesn't seem really
happy about it but we think that he will
soon forget about this picture once
he'll get the chance to inhale more food
we think that the secret of happiness is
being a dog no one could keep them from
smiling for no reason do not snore
sleeping with a pug is one of the best
things in the world they take all the
place in the bed sometimes they fart and
they always snore but as soon as a dog
cuddles you you forget everything about
that if you're wondering what your Pug
is doing when you're working you don't
have to worry all they do is be lazier
than ever they might have a lot of
energy for five minutes every day when
you come back home but they will quickly
need to recharge their batteries with a
lot of naps on the sofa with you
unfortunately for monster sleeping is
harder than he expected that's because
he snores so loud that he wakes himself
up he should be proud because not a lot
of people can do that we can't imagine
what it's like to be in this room when
monster is sleeping this is probably why
this good boy had the chance to have his
own bed and he is so sleepy that he
doesn't even mind about dog shaming no
matter what we think that these owners
are lucky to live with a dog like
monster with a funny animal like that
they should appreciate the snoring like
it's a song coming from the Angels
there's nothing you can't love when you
see a dog like that Birds this way most
birds live in nature so there is no one
to tell them how to behave they fly
wherever they want they can steal your
food if they want to and they don't mind
going to the bathroom whenever they want
even if it's on your head this is
probably why birds are a symbol of
freedom and sometimes we all wish that
we could just fly away far from our
problems just like they do and this bird
is so free that he decided that he was
not going to follow the others this is
why he decided to go in another
direction the sign might read birds this
way but this naughty animal doesn't care
at all he just wants to do his own thing
and won't listen to anyone who tells him
what to do and there's nothing wrong
with that sometimes you find the road to
success by going in another direction
but have you ever wondered how birds
know where to go when they migrate for
many birds it is just instinctive since
the day they are born they know that
they will have to travel far from where
they are at a specific time of the year
when it becomes darker outside their
brain simply responds it sets hormonal
changes and they get
ready for a big journey we just hope
that this naughty bird is not lost
he better join his group if he doesn't
want to spend the winter alone keep off
and last but not least is another good
boy
in a perfect world there would be dogs
everywhere every citizen would have the
right to own a puppy no one could keep
us from having a small one in an
apartment and we would have the right to
take them everywhere we go
this is why we are disappointed when we
see that our society sometimes rejects
animals they didn't do anything wrong
and all they want is to give love to
everyone this is why this pug decided
that the best way to save everyone was
to break the rules no matter if this
sign reads keep off this puppy will be
there to show that all the dogs does a
replace in this world some people might
not want to call him a good boy after
seeing what he did to this sign but we
don't think that he is responsible there
is no way he could have climbed on this
side so we think that his owner put him
here to take a picture this time we
think that a human will end up on the
naughty list this pug looks like he does
want to keep off if only he could do you
have a naughty pet like these funny
animals don't be shy to tell us what
they do in the comment section down
below and that's it for 10 naughty
animals who don't care about the rules
for more stories like this make sure you
watch fifteen superheroes in real life
as dogs thanks for watching and see you
next time
[Music]